I became aware of you like many people
did with the infamous Halloween costume
incident at Yale where explain that for
people who don't know what happened
because it was I'm kind of a crazy scene
it went national yes it was a moment
when around the country many students
were struggling with how to balance
conflicting sort of needs that
conflicting needs how on the one hand to
create an environment in schools where
people everyone sort of felt welcomed as
we've democratized admissions to our
American universities as I think we
should have people from all walks of
life have started moving into these
institutions claiming them for their own
which i think is appropriate but at the
same time these institutions had
wonderful Heritage's of commitment to
free expression and open debate and and
reason as a principle for resolving our
differences and that's and some of those
values came into tension and so around
the country there was a lot of heat
about this and I happened to walk into a
propellor myself and and wound up in
some challenging circumstances and you
know I it was not it was not the worst
thing that's ever happened to me but you
know it was Sid in the top 10
challenging moments I've had in my life
let's say yeah that's a very lawyer-like
way of describing exactly what happening
I you know I you know I struggle I mean
you can tell the story if you want and
then I can correct things but here's the
thing is it's my job to be a teacher and
I have taken responsibility for teaching
young people and it is the case that
many people lost their minds
I mean lost their senses and and and the
faculty too incidentally I mean you know
there it's one thing to talk about
people in there in college aged people
but then you know the faculty also
didn't necessarily do what they should
have done but um but the the thing is is
that you know my commitment it my
commitment is to is to teaching more
generally and I
to be defined by that event I don't want
that to become the most important thing
about me you know I have this book or
this book that we're going to talk about
that is an important thing in my life
instantiate smile use it talks about
what I think is important about the
world so so I'm trying to be balanced
about it just it's one thing that
happened I did my best it's in the past
let me let me help out here because
you're being so nice about the whole
thing so people know what we're talking
about there was an incident that was
captured on someone's cell phone where
you see people it was an hour of yet
it's five or six different angles so a
clip went viral but I want to emphasize
that there were many people filming that
day and an hour or more of the two or
three hours I was out there as available
but well I'm glad that you had the
courage to do that though to stand out
there and talk to those kids but some of
them were clearly there's something that
happens when people become extremely
self indulgent when they know that they
have this platform and they have someone
who is in a position of authority and
they get to hamstring them in front of
the public and that's what I felt was
going on just my understanding of human
nature I knew what she was doing what
she was doing by shouting and screaming
this is our fucking home you know I will
you know we're supposed to be safe here
I was like oh I see what's going on
she's throwing up the flag of virtue for
all of her friends to see how amazing
she was so she's putting on a show
people do that it's it's it's human
nature you handled it admirably you
stood there and you you just listen to
her and you never yelled back and you
never raise your voice and you you
remain calm but that sort of environment
where the children and I want to set
children they're basically adults but
acting like children but this is one of
the ironies the people that age you know
can fight in wars and lose their lives
and so I think it's a it's a difficult
challenge because on the one hand it's
right and appropriate to hold people
responsible for their actions certainly
if you're 20 years old you're an adult
you're still growing you're still
changing you're still learning I'm not
the same man I was when I was 20 but you
have to be responsible
your behavior yeah and so I don't think
you get a total pass either it's hard
not get a total pass and you know for
folks who don't have a 20 year old in
their life and don't remember what it
was like you know you're not a fully
formed thing yet you're you're filled
with chaos emotions and hormones and yes
and then you're at school and you're
probably away from the instructions of
your parents for the first time and you
know you're cut loose and trying out new
new ways of communicating that way it's
it's a lot of it's a mess but most
people felt horrified watching that that
you were subjected to that when you're
being very reasonable and also what it
all came about was your wife had sent
out an email saying like hey maybe it
should be okay for someone to wear a
fucked-up Halloween costume you know
maybe it's okay to for someone to dress
up like Crazy Horse we have well
actually just to be clear what Erica was
saying in that note was not this is very
important intellectual distinction I
think we've we've lost a lot of nuance
in our political lives in general in our
country right now and also in the in the
nuance in the way we think about
difficult topics so what Erica was
saying was not that necessarily the
people she was not taking a position on
any particular costumes like this is OK
in fact many of the costumes that would
have offended the students would offend
her what she was saying was that she
didn't think the university should be
telling students what to wear right she
and she was asking the students do you
students really at this age at Yale do
you really want the university to be
sending you guidance on what to wear
perhaps you should think about that
you're adults you're smart you're in an
environment that privileges free
expression do you really want to grant
the power to an institution to tell you
how to communicate yeah and people then
thought that she was saying that that
she was defending a particular course of
action what she was saying was you she
was saying do you students really want
to surrender that kind of control over
your own lives to older adults and
apparently many students did actually
they wanted dated so I don't believe
they did I think they wanted absolute
enforcement of what they thought to be
wrong or right yes yes I think that's
right so they they they they though the
many but not all of the students I mean
let's be let's also be very clear and in
part of the motivation in in Ericka
writing that note was that many many of
her students in fact many hundreds of
other students felt infantilized by this
policy and there had been a big build-up
prior to that event including an article
in The New York Times about these
Halloween costume policies around the
country and weren't they kind of
ridiculous and so there was a lot there
was a kind of a ferment where people
were saying wait a minute do we really
need adults to be told in this
institution especially given its
commitments to open expression what to
wear and keep in mind that there could
be many ways in which a costume that
offends you might not might I might not
know why so let's say you've been abused
by a priest and you were that one of the
the rules said you shouldn't amok
religion for example was what one of the
one of the provisions so so a
university-wide email went out signed by
13 people saying you know don't don't
don't mock people's deeply-held faith
traditions well what if for the sake of
argument you had been a abused by a
priest and you wanted Halloween to dress
up as a Catholic priest for example you
know holding a doll and someone else who
had a different who was Catholic was
very deeply offended by that well who
should adjudicate that like you know do
is it the role of the the institution to
come down and say yes you can express
yourself this way no you cannot and so
the argument was let the young people
learn let them sort it out themselves
let them learn by talking to each other
expressing themselves saying you know
that hurts my feelings here's why it
hurts my feelings and the other person
said oh I understand or I don't
understand I reject that reason and and
sort of buy into a kind of commitment
to free and open expression that
actually I think ultimately serves the
objectives of righteous social progress
if we really want to do better in our
society or in any society in my view we
have to create an environment where we
can talk to each other grant good faith
listen carefully make subtle
distinctions and and free people up to
express what they're thinking so we can
have a real marketplace of ideas that's
you know my commitment or my belief well
that's a wonderful belief I love it I
mean that's really I couldn't agree with
you more more enthusiastically that's
really that sounds like the best
possible environment for growing up and
learning as long as you have someone to
sort of moderate or someone to mediate
if things go sideways yes or I don't
think you necessarily need a third-party
mediator but you do need a shared
understanding of core liberal principles
and these principles do include as I
mentioned earlier a kind of commitment
to free and open expression a commitment
to debate a commitment to reason so how
are you and I going to come to a better
understanding of what is true about the
world we could fight right and then the
stronger person would decide what's
right we could vote doesn't seem quite
right either you know a 350 Cardinals
voted that Galileo was wrong
that didn't make Galileo wrong or we
could use principles of reason and
inquiry to try to appreciate the world
together right we're looking out at the
world and saying that's confusing you
know does the Sun does the earth revolve
around the Sun or does the Sun revolve
around the earth or that's confusing
should a king have monarch you know
should a king have ultimate authority in
a state or is that not how we want to
organize a state so we you and I look at
the world and debate and think about
okay and we exchange reasons and we use
evidence and ways of understanding and
studying the world that to me is the
only way to truth actually now some
people will think that religion is a way
to truth right they think that the truth
is you knows God given for example now I
am very sympathetic to religious belief
systems but I don't think that's a way
to true that it's a way to some truths
actually it's a way to some some wisdom
but
so that's what our universities in our
society our universities are officially
committed to that the models of our
universities are all about free inquiry
and pursuit of knowledge and our country
is committed to that in our bill of
rights right we have a commitment to
free and open expression freedom of
assembly freedom of religion and so
forth
and and those ground rules that in my
view make it possible for us to have a
better society and and there's more I
think well I'm sure we will get into it
no I'm sure we will again I couldn't
agree with you more yeah I just think we
need more reasonable conversations and
screaming and less shouting people down
and less mob action I yes yes the mob
action is very weird because I don't
remember it well
from the like from the Vietnam War
protests to what's going on today there
was this long gap where you didn't hear
about universities shutting down speech
yes this is fairly new this is within
the last half decade or so
well let's not yeah yes yes I mean
they're always there's there's always an
undercurrent of tension about this at
universities and in our society at large
I mean let's not forget the McCarthy era
where you had the right wing was you
know really interested in shutting down
communists like if you were a professor
or an artist who had far left political
views you were screwed yes and that's
what's wrong or even if you'd want went
to a communist meeting yes find out what
it was all about yes just to educate
yourself yes in fact that's a great
example because that like right now I
see a lot of people being criticized for
following online people they disagree
with yes which is nuts great yeah so I
just because I follow someone doesn't
mean I agree with what they're saying
I'm interested to learn what are they
saying I'm friends with people I can
agree I'm friends with so many people I
don't agree with I have a friend I have
I have friends across the political
spectrum from though I don't have any
monarchists among my friends who are
monarchies but I have friends from the
far right too far left I have a friend
who really believes he's so libertarian
he thinks there should be private
ownership of roads whoa yeah
yeah I think that's ridiculous and we
debate but you know must be white he's
actually my what my wife says she just
once like to meet a poor libertarian yes
libertarian yes
no yeah that's a ridiculous position I
think so private Rosie the fuck out yeah